my absolute favorite kamala harris
who just showed up
to give a speech
to the space force
kamala harris has very
high level speech writers at her
disposal kamala harris could make the
play right now joe biden is old he's
it's hard to imagine he's going to run
for president again this is her chance
to shine kamala what's the best that
you've got to inspire americans to elect
you in 2024 or 2028
space is
exciting it spurs
our imaginations
and it forces us
to ask
big questions
space
it affects us all
and it connects us all
i think kamala harris has been hanging
out with nicki freed
in that greenhouse
with all that peruvian parsley she does
this all the time i actually have a
kamala harris bong that i guess is not
unfortunately it's not at my desk right
now but i i'll have to spark it up in
order to even have a shot at
understanding what she's saying but from
what i can gather what kamala harris is
saying is
space man
you know
like you ever think about it man like us
but
space
you know
man
that's the substance
of her speech
you like that clip cool ring the bell
get those notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stutter google
play subscribe to the michael knowles
show podcast leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you